what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into ultimate spider-man
or I guess really Miles Morales ultimate
spider-man one thing I want to point out
here is that in these video titles I'm
simply going to call these Miles Morales
ultimate spider-man and neo volume 1
volume 2 volume 3 and so on really the
origin story that we did is volume
warrants this is more like volume 2 but
in truth this was really just kind of
called ultimate spider-man and then
there was another series later on that
followed this that was called Miles
Morales ultimate spider-man but in order
to avoid confusion between ultimate
spider-man Peter Parker and ultimate
spider-man Miles Morales we're just
gonna call this ultimate spider-man
Miles Morales so that way everything is
pretty clear and pretty easy to follow
but the cool thing about this is that
again the origin story for those of you
guys who are just joining us with
regards to the whole ultimate spider-man
landscape the ultimate universe was
never designed to be this great big huge
grandiose thing like the main Marvel
Universe I mean the main Marvel Universe
was really kind of built by Stanley Jack
Kirby Steve Ditko a handful of other
writers and artists in the 1960s and 70s
and then it grew to what it is now or
it's just massive in scope and you have
the Avengers and you have neo Excalibur
and yeah the Alpha Flight you have you
know the Brotherhood of Evil Mutants and
the x-men and so on and so forth the old
zubi universe was designed to be far
more contained in much much smaller and
scale and so the result is that when it
came to the ultimate spider-man stories
by Brian Michael Bendis the idea was to
basically keep things relatively small
to tell these small volumes where
characters would appear and then never
be seen or heard from again or else if
they were seen they were just in a
containment cell where they were being
held by shield or something along those
lines but it was very easy to digest and
it was very very easy to follow and
that's one of the reasons why the
Ultimate Universe was relatively popular
but in the end people still gravitated
toward the characters that they thought
of when they thought of Captain America
when they thought of Thor and so on and
so forth now with regards to Miles
Morales Peter Parker was basically the
recipient of a bite from a spider that
contained the odds formula and again the
whole idea here in the Ultimate Universe
was that Nick Fury I guess Samuel
Jackson it here if you want to call him
that Nick Fury was the original super
soldier and when the Super Soldier Serum
that was used on Nick Fury proved to be
successful it resulted in this great
gold rush more or less for everybody to
create their own super soldiers and so
that's where Wolverine came from
Wolverine was the recipient of Canada's
attempt to create a super soldier serum
but along
away they discovered a mutant gene that
when activated would give people powers
and that was the origin of the mutant
race in the Ultimate Universe when it
came to spider-man he had a guide Norman
Osborn who was basically trying to
create a super-soldier serum and he
created something called the oz formula
and where he was going through and
testing it on different spiders one of
these spiders bit Peter Parker which led
him to become a spider-man in the
Ultimate Universe but following the
course of his publication history
somewhere around 160 issues or so which
this is far shorter than that I think
Miles Morales stories probably totaling
like maybe 30 or 40 issues that's not
really that long at all but following
the publication history of Peter Parker
he eventually died and the reason was
because Marvel was wanting to basically
make way for a new spider-man that just
made good sense I mean you had ultimate
spider-man Peter Parker and then you had
the main Marvel Universe Peter Parker
who I have two versions of the same
character give us a new spider-man and
so that's what they did they killed off
Peter Parker
and they had it had a spider basically
bite a new kid by the name of Miles
Morales who gained Peter Parker's powers
and then a couple of his own that
petered in half for example Miles
Morales can administer this venom venom
shock which is basically kind of like an
electrical impulse that basically shocks
a person that's touching him or
something along those lines he can make
himself invisible he can camouflage
himself that kind of a thing so again
Miles was very much his own character
but the whole idea here and really where
this story begins to pick up as we start
to get into his uncle Aaron Davis now
the crazy thing about Aaron Davis's
character is that as interesting as he
is there's a lot more to him than meets
the eye it's not as clean-cut as him
just being a con man but that's how he
comes off he comes off as a con artist
he comes off as a thief and achieved but
he's actually a very capable guy and the
way this story unfolds is it's actually
going to be a sort of a battle of
allegiances so to speak for Miles
Morales himself but what is up happening
here is we actually pick up with Aaron
Davis traveling back or at least
intending to meet the tinkerer now the
tanker is basically a character who
creates devices I mean really the
tinkerer who was who we saw in the
spider-man homecoming movie that was
working alongside Michael Keaton the
other half of this is that it also deals
with the introduction of a new version
of the scorpion and the reason why I say
new version is because of the fact that
in the Peter Parker ultimate spider-man
line of comics and those stories the
Scorpion was introduced but he was
actually introduced as a clone of Peter
Parker the issue with this was that with
Brian Michael Bendis right in the story
at the time and wanting to create a new
spider-man it also made sense to give
this news
man Miles Morales his own villains to
face off against and so what ended up
happening is the scorpion as he appeared
in the original Peter Parker stories in
the Ultimate Universe uh he was
basically defeated he was revealed to be
a clone of Peter Parker and then he was
just never really seen or heard from
again after he was taken captive by
shield that was really it this version
of scorpion seems to be more in line
with the Scorpion that we saw from
spider-man homecoming the Scorpion seems
to be more grounded in terms of three
years and what he's about and that kind
of a thing his backstory still remains
pretty ambiguous and it will for a
little while but suffice it to say he's
basically in New York because of the
fact that Prowler owes him cash and
that's really about it now the other
half of this is Miles Morales trying to
make his way and trying to figure out
how to be a superhero but the other
thing to focus on here is Miles is
struggling with the exact same thing
that Peter Parker did and that's one of
the cool things about this is that what
Bendis and them are basically saying is
that no matter what universe were in for
the most part unless the character is
drastically different from who were used
to he's always going to struggle with
the same thing should he tell his
friends and family who he is and if he
does what are the consequences of that
because remember if you were to tell his
mom for example that he's spider-man she
may believe him she may not believe him
but if she has that knowledge it makes
her a target for somebody else and so
she basically can't spill the beans on
something she doesn't know anything
about and if miles never tells her then
nobody has any reason to go after her
they have no reason to connect the two
people now something else to focus on is
it again when business in them created
Miles Morales they didn't just abandon
the concept of Peter Parker in his
entirety and he's dead he doesn't show
up and he won't show up again until
spider-man but the idea here was to keep
the legacy of Peter Parker going ganky
really just kind of goes to miles it
says look it's cool that you're
spider-man but you don't really know
what you're doing and Peter Parker's not
here to teach you what you need to know
because he's dead and so you need to be
able to learn what Peter Parker knew
from Peter Parker himself the best way
you know how which is to basically watch
movies of Peter Parker fighting and
that's kind of the cool thing because
neo miles gets a video gets to watch it
you know watch footage of the Ultimate
Universe Peter Parker facing off against
Doctor Octopus nothing too significant
but his first real attempt in trying to
stand toe-to-toe and trying to really
become spider-man comes with the arrival
of a character by the name of Omega Red
now Omega red in the Ultimate Universe
was starkly different from his character
in the in the May
universe in the main Marvel Universe
Omega Red was the byproduct of the
Russians trying to duplicate Wolverine
that's really all it was it was the idea
that Wolverine had been taken by the
Weapon X project his healing factor had
been used in order to bond his body with
adamantium and the result was that he
ended up going forward it's just this
adamantium laced killing machine
the Russians try to duplicate the same
process but the difference here is that
the Russians didn't know the formula for
adamantium and so because of that they
ended up creating a cheap knockoff
called carbonadium now carbonadium is
still pretty durable and it's still
pretty potent in terms of what it's
capable of but naturally this eventually
led to of a battle of sorts between
Omega Red and Wolverine with the two of
them becoming mortal enemies in the
Ultimate Universe it was starkly
different Omega Red was basically just a
guy who was a mutant he gained these
powers that allowed him to just kind of
expand these organic tendrils from his
body he could emit toxins different
things like that but he wasn't nearly as
capable as his main Marvel counterpart
but the reason why this is important is
because of the fact that for Miles
Morales going against somebody like
Omega Red is going if someone he's never
experienced before and so it's really
him kind of on the edge of his seat
using his powers as best he can trying
to become a legitimate hero because with
trying to dodge these tendrils and so on
it requires him to use basically every
ounce of agility he has as we would
expect he comes out on top but the idea
of Aaron Davis being rolled in as part
of Miles Morales spider-man's story
comes when again Aaron Davis basically
encounters the tinkerer and is the idea
that the tinkerer you know when Aaron
Davis is looking at this newspaper about
a new spider-man and so on and so forth
the tinkerer basically gives Aaron Davis
the whole back story of how spider-man
became spider-man the original Peter
Parker became spider-man of course as we
talked about Norman Osborn created the
odds formulas and when a so forth but
this also rings a bell for the Prowler
because remember in our video on the
origin of Miles Morales he was bitten by
a spider in front of uncle Aaron Davis
and the result was that Aaron Davis saw
the spider and saw a number on and so
because of that when you know tinkerer
begins to explain all these things about
what Osborn was doing how he would
perform experiments on these spiders he
would number them and he would catalog
them in order to keep track of what his
experiments were doing and how they were
progressing Aaron Davis comes to the
realization that a numbered spider that
his nephew and then suddenly there's
this new Spider Man on the scene two and
two together Miles Morales is spider-man
and that's why say that collar
Davis is actually sharper then people
give him credit for I mean he's smarter
than your average bear
I guess but it's kind of a cool thing
because it sets the stage for this idea
of Aaron Davis being brought in asking
for some pretty nefarious things and
that's really the first thing that he
does I mean as soon as he realizes that
Myles is spider-man he goes to mrs. hey
man like we should work together like we
can put our efforts together and we can
really achieve something great now
remember Myles was informed by his
father that his uncle Aaron was a cot
with a con artist and a crook and served
time in jail Myles father was heading
down the same path and so Myles father
he basically warned him hey look do not
get in the mix with your uncle Aaron the
other half of this is that Myles father
I wouldn't go as far as to say is a very
cautious man so much as he's trying to
ensure his son stay safe but he's also a
little overprotective and this is where
the whole element of loyalties begins to
come into play because with Miles
Morales he's kind of stuck in two
different situations the first is that
he believes in his father I mean this is
his dad you know he follows his father
as best he can but it almost feels like
his father's trying to shelter him from
the world's experiences and life in and
of itself people growing and becoming
something better than they are is all
about experiences doing something stupid
and learning from that experience at the
same time is his uncle Aaron Davis and
he knows that he's a crook but if he
wants to go out and experience life
there's a lot of different ways to do
that but family's family blood is blood
and so again that's one of the
interesting things about this this story
and that's one of the reasons why I've
loved Miles Morales is character for so
long it's because it's just the inner
struggle between the two of them now
with regards to Aaron Davis having
killed a tanker so that nobody would
know about the the possibility of Miles
Morales being ultimate spider-man
it also comes into play with him I guess
reencountering scorpion again and this
is when we basically learned that
scorpion was owed money by Aaron Davis
that presumably Aaron Davis essentially
cheated him out of cash
scorpion comes back looking for his
money now the other half of this is that
we also get some perspective in terms of
what scorpions capable of and what we're
actually informed here is that he's not
just some crazy guy you know who is a
mob boss out of Mexico instead he does
have some abilities and one of the most
notable is a highly resistant skin Aaron
Davis ultimately descends up fleeing for
his life when he begins to realize just
how capable scorpion is and then he's
not really a pushover and now of course
this leads to exactly what we would
expect it to in the sense that Aaron
Davis essentially flees to his nephew
miles morales and this is probably one
of the best elements of the story and
the reason for this is because Aaron
Davis approaching his nephew is done
from ill intent like it's him showing up
and essentially having this interior
motive there's a guy trying to kill me I
want to try to take him out so on and so
forth but he doesn't say that he doesn't
go to Miles Morales and say hey man I
did something really bad I screwed a guy
over in Mexico and he got here to New
York and he's trying to kill me you got
to help me take this guy out that's not
what he says instead what he does is he
pawns it off on the idea of being a
tutor of sorts and that's kind of the
cool thing because Aaron Davis uses you
know basically the abilities of a suit
combined with his own experiences to
engage miles in hand-to-hand combat and
this is why I say sometimes despite the
fact that there can be no farías
purposes here at the end of the day
there is still something to be learned
and so while Aaron Davis is trying to
manipulate his own nephew Aaron Davis is
teaching Myles how to become a more
effective fighter because remember Myles
doesn't have any martial arts training
he doesn't have military training
he has no kind of training at all he's a
kid who was bitten by a radioactive
spider and then suddenly has all these
powers and so he doesn't know how to
fight he doesn't have any of that kind
of training stuff he's really just
flying by the seat of his pants every
step of the way
in every single conflict he gets into
now the other half is to remember he
learns as he goes through and that's
kind of the cool thing is because he's
literally learning to fight while he's
fighting and so that's one of the the
crazy things about his character and his
evolution but the idea of Aaron Davis is
saying look I'm trying to help you out
here now Aaron is not totally evil like
he's not a total bad guy he's not just
like I don't care whether you live or
die I'm just trying to make sure that
this guy scorpion gets off my back
instead it's really this idea that he's
going to him and he's saying look I
don't want to see you killed and that
really is one of the reasons why Aaron
Davis's character is so intricate and is
so complex is because on 1/2 he's a
thief he's a con artist he's a
manipulator but at the other half that's
family
that's his nephew the last spider-man
was killed by his own enemies it'd be a
lot easier for Miles Morales to be
killed by different foes
because he doesn't have nearly the
experience or the training that Peter
Parker had and so again it's kind of a
cool scenario now of course ultimately
Miles is able to overcome Aaron Davis to
the point that he proves that he's able
to hold his own to a degree and this is
where the conversation begins to unfold
is because Aaron Davis basically says I
want to train you I want to make you a
good fighter I want to turn you into
somebody who can be a legitimate soup
and this is why is kind of this idea
that these two characters have
conflicting sides where you know Aaron
Davis is just kind of a small-time crook
and a conman
and Miles Morales is trying to be a good
guy at the end of the day they have a
common goal and the common goal is to
take out an even worse bad guy named
scorpion and so that's the common ground
that the two of them reside on at this
moment it allows the characters to sort
of progress and to grow and so on and so
forth and so where we ultimately have
miles it's kind of cruising the internet
and trying to learn about this scorpion
character and we eventually have him
just sort of mulling this entire
situation over and then ultimately
agreeing to side with his uncle Aaron
against the wishes of his parents after
learning that this guy's scorpion has
engaged in acts of racketeering murder
theft violating other human beings this
guy is just a genuinely terrible human
being and so because of that you know
ultimately miles ends up siding with us
with uncle which again sets the stage
for some pretty cool stuff but with that
being said guys if you are new here to
come as explained and make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
Rob port if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and leave a
comment down below let me know how you
guys feel about Miles Morales as
character I know some people love him I
know some people just don't like him
they prefer you know the the classic
Peter Parker there's nothing wrong with
that but let me know how you guys feel
about Miles Morales because he's always
been one of my favorite characters
really more because I could identify
with Miles Morales more so that I could
with Peter just because of Miles Morales
his experience and where he is and you
know it's parents and so on and so forth
but anyway guys I'm gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Applause]